♪ ♪
>> Greg: DONALD TRUMP JUST
ANNOUNCE HE'S GIVING OUT THE
MOST DISHONEST AND CORRUPT MEDIA
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
HAVE YOU NOTICED THE MEDIA IS AN
OBJECT OF CRITICISM FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THE MEDIA SEEMS AS ROBUST AS
EVER.
EVERYONE IS EITHER A WOODWARD OR
BERNSTEIN WHEN THEY AREN'T HIGH.
WELCOME REDUCTION FROM THE
BLOODSHED THAT MADE ITS MAYOR OR
A TARGET OF TRUMP'S IRE.
WHY DIDN'T THIS REDUCTION OCCUR
UNDER OBAMA?
THE AGGRESSIVE JOURNALISM AND
AGGRESSIVE POLICING ARE ACTUALLY
DUE IN PART TO THE "PROVE TRUMP
WRONG" EFFECT.
FOX NEWS RAILED AGAINST MEDIA
BIAS.
THE NEXT FEW YEARS WE HAVE
COVERED CHICAGO'S PROBLEMS.
DID RAHM EMANUEL LISTEN AT ALL?
NO.
NOW WE ARE SEEING THE MEDIA
ADJUST ITS BEHAVIOR OVER
ISN'T HIS BEST FRIEND PUTS MORE
HATE TRUMP SO MUCH THAT THEY
CAN'T LET HIM WIN THE ARGUMENTS
OF THE UP THEIR GAME JUST TO
SHUT THE GUY UP.
TRUMP'S TWEETS ABOUT CHICAGO,
IRAN, THE MEDIA.
GERALDO, DON'T YOU THINK THE
MEDIA IS EXTRA MOTIVATED?
EVERY TIME THEY SCREW UP,
THEY'VE GOT TO LISTEN TO TRUMP
MAKE FUN OF THEM.
>> Geraldo: I THINK -- I AM
OLD ENOUGH TO HAVE LIVED THROUGH
WORSE PRESS THAN PRESIDENT NIXON
WORSE PRESS THAN PRESIDENT NIXO
PRESIDENT NIXON.
I THINK ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING HE
DOES IS CONSTRUED IN THE MOST
WEEK, NEXT MONDAY, IT'S A
FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE
THE STORY OF HOW
ACADEMIC -- EPIDEMIC.
THERE WAS NO CHOLERA EPIDEMIC.
I NOMINATE HIM THE NOBEL
LAUREATE ECONOMIST FOR WHATEVER
HE'S GOING TO CALL THESE.
KIMBERLY, DO YOU HAVE ANY
NOMINATIONS?
EVERYBODY ON CNN.
DON   DON LEMON, JAKE TAPPER.
THEY WILL BE LOSING IT, FREAKING
OUT.
I'M SURE THEY ARE ACTUALLY QUITE
SITUATION.
HE IS BEHIND THE WHEEL, SAYING
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT I
THINK ABOUT YOU.
THAT'S IT.
I'M GOING TO TELL THE WHOLE
WORLD THAT I LIKE THE APPROACH.
ON THE INTERNATIONAL STAGE, AS
IT RELATES TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
IMMIGRATION, TAXES, IT'S HIS
APPROACH.
>> Geraldo: YOU DON'T THINK IT
THREATENS THE FIRST AMENDMENT?
>> Kimberly: I THINK THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS SOLID.
>> Greg: DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT
IS, DANA?
LIKE, WHAT ARE YOUR PREDICTIONS
FOR 2018?
THIS IS A GUY BORN AND BRED
IS GOING TO HAVE THE BEST
RATINGS.
LAUGH, IF IT HOLDS YOU UP FOR
RIDICULE IN THE MEDIA, I DON'T
AND MAYBE EVEN FUN.
I DO THINK THERE IS SOMETHING TO
BE SAID ABOUT HOW OTHER
COUNTRIES USE IT AGAINST THEIR
OWN PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> Geraldo: DO YOU REALLY?
I HEARD THAT ARGUMENTS MY
I TRAVEL A LOT AND NO ONE COMES
UP TO ME AND SAYS SEE, YOU ARE
FAKE NEWS IN AMERICA.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO THEY COME UP
TO YOU AND SAY?
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO SAY
SELF
SELFIE.
>> Jesse: WE ARE WATCHING THE
TRUMP SHOW AND IT'S ON AT 5:00.
>> Jesse: LIKE YOU SAID, THE
MEDIA BEING MORE FAIR AND
BALANCED.
EITHER THAT, OR HE'S JUST
BRANDING THEM PHONY LOSERS.
>> Greg: LIKE RAHM EMANUEL.
NOW HE'S DOING THIS.
HE DIDN'T DO IT UNDER OBAMA.
MEDIA HAS ENOUGH SELF-AWARENESS
TO COURSE CORRECT.
IF I WERE THE CNN PEOPLE, I
WOULD MAKE FUN OF HIS HAIR.
FOCUS ON NORTH KOREA AND LAUGH
ABOUT IT.
>> Kimberly: THEY ARE